so anyway i guess here we go mariah
carey is playing no games when it comes
to her coven 19 vaccine
it's amazing the singer shared a video
of herself getting the first dose on
instagram
and she was a little nervous oh yeah
of course in typical mariah fashion she
belted not one
not two but three high notes in the
process
and although she tells us this is only
part one she wants everyone to know that
we're still all in this together
we are hoping for the best encouraging
you guys to um
i would do it when you can last march
mariah raised awareness about the
importance of staying safe during
coronavirus
by posting a tick tock with her
nine-year-old twins munro and moroccan
washing their hands to the singer's hit
single fantasy
20 seconds me and mariah go back like
babies
mariah also delivered this quarantine
rendition of her song
it's like that
and although that time there were no
high notes involved
it's hardly the first time mariah has
impressively belted impromptu style in
july she gave us a slightly different
way to conquer the bottle cap challenge
on tick-tock
she also hilariously showed us that when
it comes to her signature high notes
the apple doesn't fall far from the tree
with her daughter monroe
[Music]
mommy what you said do the high notes
okay so mariah did throw in a little
help here and there
well they love being on stage my twins
rock and roll
love being on the stage in 2017 the
superstar opened up to e.t about her
kids following in her famous footsteps
they want to watch themselves but they
want to be on the stage so actually the
other day i was just teaching
miss monroe the you'll always be a part
of me
and just singing that to her and she has
a really good ear so she was
she was learning it i don't know if she
could hear herself on stage they were
singing along
which i saw which was so cool so
they're amazing they're so brave they
really are i'm
i'm very i'm very proud of them